see it's Sunday
she pulled me in here making me want to
do one of these damn videos well we have
to do one every day now we don't have to
sad you guys are [ __ ] tired
who said that somebody in this dance
somebody somebody yeah so what did you
want to talk about it you have anything
to tell no I was just like talking about
let's see what did I what did we do last
night I was like I didn't feel that good
it was Saturday night and one drink
because hungover
I watched killer clowns from outer space
yeah movie looked pretty good I am God
man I hadn't seen that since I was a kid
that was on shudder I think when uh no
Netflix is on Netflix yeah and I was
like watch I was like man I forgot how
[ __ ] cool this movie looked yeah 87
88 and another thing I forgot to is that
the [ __ ] dude that played
Deathstalker in Deathstalker and the
warriors from hell on MST yeah that
[ __ ] was in this recipe I said
the whole time I'm like [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
nuts Tucker god I hate that smug son
last time I had seen last time I'd seen
the movie it was like on VHS yeah our
regular like CRT style television it
looked like [ __ ] but you look at it now
man it's you know on a good television
it blu-ray quality the movie is a pretty
it's a pretty movie the Lighting's good
taking all the props the costumes it
looks cool I'm saying like I I was like
if somebody had the money and you know
after the pandemic thing is over and
people can like go out again how cool
would it be to have a nightclub that
look that was like a complete replica of
the inside of the killer Klowns Big Top
spaceship yeah with all the [ __ ]
stripy yeah they had something like that
it was called cafe Hollywood or what was
that [ __ ] remember that restaurant chain
these two have playing at Planet
Hollywood yeah that looked like that did
it okay I went in I went in one in
Orlando and I don't remember it looking
like that I just remember a bunch of
like memorabilia I think every one of
them is a little bit different yeah I
think they were
to me they just look like [ __ ] really
gaudy like Disneyland [ __ ] circus so
I could [ __ ] everything looked like
the inside of a [ __ ] AMC theater yeah
that's what it kind of looked like but I
don't know I always thought it'd be
really cool if you could have like the
the [ __ ] cotton candy cocoons there
and like all the [ __ ] crazy circusy
looking [ __ ] yeah but yeah and I forgot
about the little popcorn that moved yeah
special effects are really good yeah and
like the [ __ ] clouds looked really
good too and then after that I was like
for some reason I was watching that and
I was like man this makes me want to
watch Beetlejuice like for the
thousandth time but they didn't have it
on shudder or Netflix and I didn't feel
like renting it and I don't think I have
it on DVD anywhere I haven't seen that
one along so I ended up just watching
corpse bride which was on Netflix which
I don't like as much but it's you know
it's good but it's not like Nightmare
Before Christmas good I was uh getting
into second YouTube I wasn't interested
in that I saw it in the theater um when
it came out but I don't think that I saw
it after that so I was kind of
interested to see it again it looks
beautiful and like a lot of but it's the
songs aren't quite as memorable um it's
just Tim Burton man being so Tim Burton
tea which I like that sometimes he can
get - Tim Burton ish but at least this
one was animated yeah I mean it wasn't a
kind of thing where he was trying to do
like [ __ ] Johnny Depp being weird
like a [ __ ] I mean Johnny Depp did
did one of the voices in this he did the
voice of like Viktor Benson or whatever
the kid's name was but yeah and but at
least you didn't have to like look at
him like with this [ __ ] surely you
know the [ __ ] Willy Wonka yeah for me
I think I think Burton's best thing in
recent years would have been the demon
the demon street barber what was it
called Sweeney Todd Sweeney Todd yeah
that was it yeah I saw that in the
theater too and then like we watched it
again like probably a couple months ago
and I had forgotten how [ __ ] good
that was yeah that's a good one I mean
the look of that is like really cool and
a lot of the songs are cool
I remember when I saw it in the theater
it wasn't I was kind of bummed out I'd
never seen the musical and so I was kind
of like uh the music was like too
musically for me I guess it's like it
would have been cooler if it was like
gothy er to go along with the look but I
guess I got over that like the second
time I watched it but yeah so it's like
I still like corpse bride like the look
of it's cool the little character
designs are cool and [ __ ] like that but
I don't know it's just it doesn't have
the same charm as like Nightmare Before
Christmas I think it seems like kind of
a pale imitation of that a couple days
back Johnny Depp did his first little
foray into social media you know because
there's something about his ex-wife his
ex-wife's acted a fool
doing all kinds of [ __ ] evidently she
was taking the jump in a bed and all
kinds of weird stuff that she had done
okay yeah she does some prank and it
just all kind of came out deer nut I
guess they're getting a divorce or
something is that what this is yeah some
kind of divorce I don't know it was
there was there was domestic abuse but I
don't know which side it was on or if it
was both sides yeah if they were both
beating each other up I was beating up
the other one I don't really know I
haven't like I said I'm a whole [ __ ]
thing the whole thing the whole thing's
a [ __ ] mess and evidently the way she
was acting pretty much ever most
everybody is kind of like stuff came out
and everybody's kind of siding with Depp
that she was really putting him through
the [ __ ] ringer you know so he
decides to come out and do this first
little I guess it's a YouTube video or
something
mm-hm and he just could not stop being a
movie star he was trying to be a regular
guy he's trying to be a youtuber and it
just looks really [ __ ] uncomfortable
although I felt bad for him
really yeah I did I felt bad for him I
could tell that he was very felt very
uncomfortable being unscripted and he
seems very uncomfortable trying to
relate to the odd - just annoys he can't
be a regular guy to the rest of us the
rest to the rest of the right yeah
cannot be a regular guy just just watch
the video well some when you're at that
but when you're as famous as [ __ ]
Johnny Depp for example
I would imagine that you don't really
have too much interaction with normal
people I mean you're just surrounded
with other tribes wealthy people are
other people in showbiz yeah he's really
trying in the video you can see you know
he tries to like come down to our level
to talk to us that's kind of what it
feels like you don't advance Johnny he's
trying to be our friend
yeah to try to thank us for seeing what
kind of [ __ ] he's going throughout
that's basically what it was motive his
motive was on that so he just did he's
trying to encourage everybody during the
pandemic to keep themselves occupied and
you know play board games and you just
got to see it you know III I think I
don't know I can't watch like that kind
of crunchy stuff it was [ __ ] crazy he
was trying to just I get like contact
embarrassment yeah embarrassed but I
feel embarrassed for him well that's
what I mean I don't like that feeling I
don't really I could tell he felt
embarrassed you know he's like how the
[ __ ] do you mean how do you do it
YouTube probably like I don't know the
guy or anything like that but I have
heard he's a little bit weird he's weird
I mean it's nothing wrong with weird
people obviously but he's very detached
from reality it seems like from normal
life and he kind of says that you know I
mean yes this is my first I've never
been on social media yeah well he's got
like stage fright talking to the camera
unscripted you know oh that makes me
feel kind of better though cuz I mean as
long as we've been doing this show um
you know and now we're doing it like
every day it's like I still get nervous
like before I don't get nervous so much
doing these because these are just like
what the [ __ ] ever and it's like if we
run out of [ __ ] to talk about and just
turn it off you know what I mean but
doing the the regular episodes and to us
to a lesser extent that movie reviews
because I actually have to like have
facts and notes and [ __ ] like that
so I don't forget things and you know so
I get more paranoid about that because I
feel like I'm gonna mess some fact up
and I mean I know I can fix it
and editing but I don't like to have you
see you know when you come up like when
you go through drama when you go through
drama like drama school or drama club or
whatever you know you got to get you
guys put on live productions you know
musicals and stuff get roles I was in
several over me and my buddy Steve we
were getting landing all the leads and
stuff in the musical so did L guy oh and
fantasticks and I did I did [ __ ]
Farrow at a Joseph and the Amazing
Technicolor Dreamcoat I know I even
remember most of my lyrics from those
and you you rehearse a long time
you're never going into the situation
blind it's a you know physical as a
control same thing when we were doing
you know just regular plays it's highly
controlled you might feel a little bit
of stage fright on opening night but
when you go through a couple of nights
and [ __ ] you know the crowd [ __ ]
loves it it gets very easy and very
reassuring and that's what Deb's his
just do it you know I mean yeah he he
knows how to be in a very controlled and
situation and he knows how are you doing
my ass so here's a classy Pookie
so he does never feel any kind of stage
fright because you know there's no you
know everything's a very controlled
situation but when the social media is
not controlled it's ad-libbing yeah you
can tell that he's putting on a
performance he's trying to put on a
performance but he doesn't know his
lines yeah that's the situation I mean I
used to do I used to be in the chorus so
I did used to like have to sing and
burning people and [ __ ] like that
yeah um which always made me nervous but
like I said you know I at least said I
didn't usually have to like sing by
myself would you really really would
have like freaked me out man I used to
have to do [ __ ] solos and [ __ ]
without without a microphone oh yeah you
have to like just natural projection
yeah yeah cuz I had
- I took chorus for years and years and
years but you know I was back that's
back when I wanted to be an actor
yes yeah you know of course you know I
have friends that ended up making it you
know I think everybody knows that you
know was there was an actress named Mary
Ellen rice Cup is my ex-girlfriend she's
24 yeah she was on 24 that's my
ex-girlfriend and we're still friends
she's awesome and I'm just oh no once I
got through drama I realized I don't
want to be an actor I didn't like the
people and it's a good thing cuz it a
Casti casting couch the [ __ ] out of me
an apt isn't [ __ ] cute as you were
cute as I was an actor is a beggar when
he's not working yeah um I I always felt
like it was more like I I never wanted
when I was growing up I never wanted
like a regular job like I had one for a
really long time just because but I I
was always more like more appealing to
me as like being a writer doing things
like that because you know you can still
be famous you can still make money and
stuff like that but you don't have to
like get out in front of people all the
time you don't have to I don't know I
just felt like I acting to me which
seemed like it would be really I guess
I'm just not good at like pretending to
be something else yeah some people are
good at that and I'm not good at that
like I'm not a good liar I'm not a good
nothing like that like I'm just really
not good at faking I'd like to just
immerse myself into the role and I just
put trip a switch and I'd become that
that yeah after for that I've heard that
other people that are actors they do
that as well the thing is though is that
it's a good thing I didn't do that for a
long time and join them join the army
instead because I think if you do that
for too long it ends up being bad for
your mental health because you don't
have a real you yeah because you keep
organized complaint all you do next I'm
faking it and faking it faking it faking
it that's why I said that you know a lot
of people [ __ ] bag on Tom Cruise I
got a lot of respect for Tom Cruise
because he came from that situation yeah
baking and faking it faking it but he
didn't want to be a fake
yeah he got involved with that damn
Scientology and he actually learned how
to ride motorcycles and fly helicopters
and do you know I mean he didn't want to
come up he want to be a fake yeah he
wanted to do real [ __ ] but what's he
gonna do join the airforce and become a
[ __ ] was gonna come out this year I
don't know what I'm sure I think it's a
Chinese friendly Top Gun movie I'm chose
to bite the knob yeah there's like a
little wooden knob on the desk here and
she for some reason she loves fighting
that thing she wooden things and she
likes that specific I think she thinks
that's the only reason that that's there
cuz it's a kitty is for Pookie to chew
on yeah it's a kitty chew and she was
like I have like all kind of little
[ __ ] two sticks and little twigs and
[ __ ] like that for chew on as you can't
figure out these lights she's like what
are these lights do I respectfully you
can't do anything without her gonna get
there she's like what I need to get
involved in this [ __ ] what are you doing
I can't even like make the bed without
her helping like jumping on there but
yeah so what else we got to talk about
probably purchasing it not everybody
keep the channel rolling keep you guys
moving forward through the pandemic
moving forward and a lot of the [ __ ]
that Nostradamus has said is coming true
with all this [ __ ] with you know they
got now you got little riots
demonstrations breaking out trying to
drop the the quarantine in certain areas
they will they will they're gonna people
are ready to get back to work man you
can't run it like this they say well the
outbreak will continue they're not that
they don't give a [ __ ] they're gonna
open up and they're gonna absorb those
casualties watch don't you're gonna have
Mad Max out here yeah and there are
certain industries that will never if
they shut down will never start back up
you know and a lot of those industries
involve food or power and you need that
food you need that electricity when that
electricity is gone your world is gonna
be [ __ ] up
sucks yeah we need electricity I mean
you just can't live in Florida without
electricity yeah I mean in two days the
house smells like [ __ ] Dagobah yeah I
mean one percent human value better just
like [ __ ] sleep because it's out
there too but it's nearly a hundred
degrees on a hundred percent humidity
yeah it's like everything the walls
start to sweat
yeah and the houses aren't built for it
not really you'd think they would be but
they're just not that's it I guess it's
too expensive too expensive they're
built like most houses are built
nowadays for hurricanes they're just to
be able to withstand hurricanes of up to
however however many miles per hour but
a florida house was only built the last
30 years 40 years they figure you're
probably tear it down build something
else there anyway probably new ones that
they're making yeah I think what how old
is this house twelve yes my 12 years old
I think this is only like 10 and they're
made out of materials that where if
they're if the air conditioning isn't
running in them they just start falling
apart yeah pretty quickly as it turns
out yeah plus we got every [ __ ] kind
of plant the bug and getting like that
out there it'll just take over the whole
[ __ ] jet every bit of bacteria starts
to [ __ ] multiply looking like the
outside world is Logan's Run why can't
he just like covered with [ __ ] [ __ ]
playing look at some of those damn event
those damned urban exploration channels
you know of stuff that they'll find here
in the south stuff that's been abandoned
for [ __ ] ten years and like they used
to be luxury apartments and now the
carpet is just one big madam boss yeah
I've got [ __ ] plans still looks like
carpet but it's all [ __ ] all the all
the walls are black for black mold
growing in them uh-huh just yeah you
gotta wear [ __ ] you aspirator in
there yeah but yeah so uh anyway have a
good rest of your weekend
and we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow